we're going back to comic-con the idea
obviously is to kick last year's but we
have to make sure that this will
actually work and we're back to the
drawing board now we're through the
design phase we know what we're gonna
build the next step is to prove that
it's possible
that's where prototyping comes in so
pretty much today what I need to do is
prove that this concept can work that we
can have multiple people this will have
one person down below probably three
people up here so that's the concept is
that this is going to be the largest
autonomous free walking character that
we've ever done this is all human power
so getting something this big to move
around is you've got to test it you know
okay will that arm actually move can we
actually make an arm that's eight feet
long
move by one guy it's huge its massive I
mean I don't know if the cameras caught
it but my favorite moment in that little
meeting we just had was went out and
looked at that printout of his creation
and then looked over at the amp suit it
was like I saw that arm printed out I
was like we're so screwed I don't know
how we're gonna do this one way we like
to refer to prototyping in the creature
effects industry is a garbage bag test
this goes all the way back to aliens and
Stan Winston studio and that's how they
prove the alien queen would even be
possible as a puppet we'll apply the
same principles to giant creature we
started out the build with
improve the concept of the base which
was to see if three people can get up
there on a three-wheeled vehicle and
have it be stable it's huge
14 feet tall is it safe is it center
gravity with that many people that much
higher can it move can it drive around
and you know is it gonna fall over or
not
and from there we basically learn from
that where our weak points were and we
started doing heavier steel work wasn't
a doubt that we couldn't make a work
with the three wheels it's just how much
steel stuff we have to put in there to
make it safe
then we built the real thing we've built
the wool frame the real base and then
while that was going on I was also
prototyping the arm the other real
challenge mechanically was creating this
arm mechanism which had to be prototype
in order for us to figure out how it
would work and how it perform last year
the big problem was getting the movement
of the shoulder in line with the
puppeteers shoulder if it was out of
line then that caused a lot of stress I
think with a bigger arm now the problem
is gonna be worse so we just want to get
a nice shoulder move somehow that we can
also bungee assist the big challenge
about these arms is that they're huge
and we know they're going
so that's where prototyping is essential
it's got a two-to-one so it's actually
harder to lift but we're not worried
about that because if this Bungie
assists so it only has to move 45
degrees for the arm to go 90 so it'll be
less work for the puppeteer as far as
how far he needs to move his arm
we figured out the geometry and now
we've gone back in and we're starting
the real build which includes bearings
and making sure everything's strong
enough and light enough that it's gonna
work to the best of its ability given
our schedule the prototyping helps a lot
for us to visualize it but I try and
approach anything of this scale with a
kind of stupidly optimistic attitude
that it's all just gonna work but you
know it always breaks when it's in front
of an audience so that's the part we're
trying to avoid it's all doable if you
have enough time and money that's that's
the biggest the biggest glitch here is
we've got a deadline and let's we can
get them to push back Comic Con a couple
weeks I'd go to wired calm for the
entire giant creature series